اهلا بكم انتهت المهله التي حددها
الحوثيون للاحزاب السياسيه اليمنيه لسد
الفراغ السياسي في البلاد وسط تساؤلات عن
قدره جماعه انصار الله على اداره دوله اكد
مسؤول يمني رفيع للجزيره انها لن تكون
قادره على دفع رواتب فبراير الجاري
للموظفين نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين الى اين تسير الاوضاع المعيشيه
لليمنيين بعد احكام الحوثيين سيطرتهم على
مفاصل
الدوله وهل يملك الحوثيون القدره على
مواجهه ثوره جياع محتمله بعد انقضاء بهله
سد الفراغ
السياسي
انغمس اليمنيون اكثر فاكثر في تعقيدات
ازمتهم التي اشتدت خاصه بعد سيطره
الحوثيين على مفاصل الدوله ازمه انهكت
الدوله واحكمت قبضتها على حياه اليمنيين
لتزيد ظروفهم المعيشيه قسوه منذره بالاسو
في ظل ما اكده مسؤول يمني رفيع للجزيره من
ان الدوله ستكون عاجزه عن توفير رواتب شهر
فبراير بسبب شح شديد في الموارد مشهد يراه
متابعون مقدمه لثوره جياع تنتظر الحوثيين
الذين باتوا الحاكم الفعلي للبلاد في
المرحله
الراهنه تدخل البلاد في فراغ رئاسي تشل
مرافقها الرئيسيه ويخرج هؤلاء وهم بالالاف
الى الشوارع منددين او مؤيدين احد اطراف
الصراع لكن احدا لا يسال من اين ياكل
هؤلاء ومن هي الجهه التي تؤمن لهم قوت
يومهم على ان وهده اليومي بتفاصيله قد تجر
الصراع في اليمن لا الى هزيمه بينه لهذا
الطرف او ذاك بل الى ما هو اسوا انهيار
الدوله نفسها وفي التفاصيل ما يعض فلا
رواتب للشهر الحالي ونصف موظفي الادارات
الحكوميه لم يتسلموا بعد رواتبهم عن الشهر
الماضي ورغم عدم وجود ارقام دقيقه الا ان
بعض الخبراء يقدرون خساره اليمن بنحو خمسه
مليارات دولار من ايرادات النفط جراء
عمليه الانتقال السياسي سيره هناك عطف على
ذلك تراجع انتاج النفط نفسه في الشهور
القليله الماضيه الى نحو النصف وهو الذي
يشكل نحو 70% من مداخيل البلاد وتجميد
المنح الخليجيه التي تقدر بنحو مليار ونصف
المليار دولار فثم عجز مستفحل في
الميزانيه سعى الرئيس المستقيل لسده برفع
جزئي عن الدعم الذي تقدمه الدوله للوقود
وهو ما استغله الحوثيون في مظاهرات كان
عنوانها المعلن اسقاط ما يسمى الجرعه
وهدفها اسقاط البلاد في ايديهم على ما
يذهب خصومهم وساهمت وقائع الايام الماضيه
في اشاعه حاله ذعر لدى المستثمرين الى
درجه دفعت بعض شركات النفط لتعليق اعمالها
جزئيا وما يخشاه بعض اليمنيين ان تمتد
ايادي الاكثر قوه في الشوارع والميادين
الى ودائع البنك المركزي مما قد يؤدي الى
انهيار العمله الوطنيه بهذا يصبح ما هو
اقتصادي محض لا عسكري او سياسي من يتحكم
بمصير الدوله وهو ما يفسر الاهميه البالغه
للبعد الاقليمي لاحداث اليمن ففيما يعتصم
الجوار الخليجي باستراتيجيه الامن اولا في
مقاربه ما يوصف بزلزال اليمن يبدو ان فمهت
من قد يغامر من بوابه المال للقبض على
مفاتيح السياسه ونفوذها ايران
مثلا موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا من
صنعاء جمال الحضرمي مستشار الرئيس رس
الوزراء المستقيل كما ينضم الينا من صعد
عبر الهاتف محمد البخيتي عضو المجلس
السياسي لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين اهلا
بضيفي الكريمين استاذ جمال الوضع
الاقتصادي في اليمن معروف والتق الدولي
تؤكد صعوبه الوضع الاقتصادي في البلد ولكن
ان يصل الى عدم القدره على توفير رواتب
الموظفين الى اي مدى هذا دقيق
وصحيح الحقيقه اكدت الايام الماضيه ان
توقف تدفق الايرادات
المركزيه اللامركزيه الى المركز وتوقف
ايضا الكثير من دافعي الضرائب عن دفع
ضرائبهم وكذلك حجم الايرادات التي تحققت
من النفط خلال الفتره الماضيه او بالتحديد
ما بين عام 2014 و2013 انخفاض بالنسبه
لتكل عن 50
جعل من الصعوبه بمكان ان تقوم الدوله
بتوفير السيوله النقديه الكافيه لتغطيه
مثل هذا العجز على الرغم من ان وزاره
الماليه تؤكد انها قادره على دفع هذه
الرواتب ولو بشكل
متقطع يعني
كيف القضيه الاقتصاديه في اليمن تفضل انا
اسمعك تفضل وصل القضيه الاقتصاديه في
اليمن
هي القضيه الاقتصاديه في اليمن هي ان
الاقتصاد اليمني هو اقتصاد ريعي نفطي
يعتمد اعتمادا كبيرا عليه فكان
لاثار توقف النفط واثار الصراعات السياسيه
خلال الفترات الماضيه اثرا بالغا مما جعل
هذه هذا هذا التاثير ينعكس على الصراع
طبعا على كيان الدوله وعلى قوتها وعلى
تواجدها سيد محمد البخيتي الان انتم انصار
الله الحوثيين تمسكون بمقالي
بالتالي تتحملون المسؤوليه فيما قد تؤول
اليه الاوضاع في اليمن كيف ستتصرف مع هذه
الاشكاليه لا سيوله لتقديم على الاقل
الرواتب
للناس بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم سبب الازمه الاقتصاديه في اليمن هو
استشراء الفساد في مؤسسات الدوله وايضا
عدم توتر بيئه صالحه للاستثمار في اليمن
وايضا اضيف الى هذه المشاكل مشكله انخفاض
اسعار النفط النقط حيث ان اليمن تقريبا قد
خسرت نصف دخلها من النصر وهذه طبعا مشكله
اضافيه
و نحن نسعى الان لتشفي منافع الفساد وكذلك
توفير بيئه صالحه للاستثمار مما سيخفف من
حده الازمه الاقتصاديه في
اليمن
لان الفساد هو حقيقه من انهك الاقتصاد
اليمني حيث ان ثلاثه ارباع ايرادات الدوله
المتاحه ت في الفساد يعني الفساد ليس
فقط في الميزانيه وانما ايضا ما قبل دخول
الايرادات الميزانيه فالفساد في الدوله في
مؤسسات الدوله كبير طيب لنبدا سيد محمد
لنبدا خطوه خطوه والان يسمعك اليمنيون
بالنسبه لرواتب هذا الشهر شهر فبراير ما
الفعل ما
عملكم
طبعا سيتم دفع الان يدفع رواتب الموظفين
لم تتوقف دفع الرواتب ولكن هناك حالات
مثلا من من بعض الموظفين
الذين لا يشتغلون لا يعدون اعمالهم مثل
مثلا بعض الجنود الذين يستلمون مرتباتهم
في البيوت وكذلك بعض المدرسين والموظفين
تم قطع مرتباتهم او وقف مرتباتهم ايضا
هناك وقف لمرتبات بعض الموظفين حتى يتم
التحقق من مدى ا قيامهم بوظائفهم ف ولكن
دفع الرواتب لا زالت مستمره ولم تتوقف اذا
ربما ما فهمته من كلامك توجد سيوله وهناك
امكانيه لدفع الرواتب ولكن فقط تجفيف
منابع الفساد تحديد من يمكن له الراتب
وفقط عمليه تنظيميه ولا وجود لازمه في
السيوله بالتاكيد طبعا نحن كنا نتوقع ان
يكون هناك ازدهار اقتصادي سريع في اليمن
بعد تشيب منابع الفساد وكذلك توفير بئه
صالح على الاستثمار ولكن نتيجه للانخفاض
المتسارع لاسعار
النفط يعني نتوقع ان يستمر الوضع على ما
هو عليه فتره معينه وبعد ذلك سيعاود
الاقتصاد النهوض خصوصا مع توفير بيئه
اقتصاديه صالحه المستثمرين لانه بالمناسبه
الفساد لا ينحصر فقط في قضيه هدر الموارد
الدوله الموارد المتاحه الدوله والتي
تقارب ثلاثه ارباع الميزانيه ميزانيه
الدوله ولكن ايضا مشكله عدم توفير
فرص مناسبه للقطاع الخاص حيث ان الكثير من
المسؤولين في اليمن تحولوا الى تجار
وبالتالي اصبحت اليمن طارده للمستثمرين
ليس فقط للذين ياتون للذين يريدون
الاستثمار في اليمن من الخارج وانما ايضا
دعني دعني استمع لراي خبير اقتصادي وهو
معنا التحق بنا الان من صنعاء الاستاذ مصط
نصر وهو رئيس مركز الاعلام الاقتصادي سيد
مصطفى كيف توصف الوضع الحالي للاقتصاد
اليمني هل خطوات تجفيف منابع الفساد
وعمليه تنظيميه بالامكان تجاوز الازمه
الحاليه تتقول عن هناك صعوبه حتى في توفير
الرواتب للموظفين هذا
الشهر شكرا جزيلا الحقيقه شكرا لك
ومشاهدين والكرام ولضيوفك الكرام ايضا في
الحقيقه ان الاقتصاد الوطني خلال المرحله
الراهنه يعاني من تدهور كبير وربما اذا ما
استمرت المعطيات الراهنه قد يتجه نحو
الانهيار الكامل بسبب معطيات عده اولا
تراجع اسعار النفط وتراجع كميه النفط
المنتجه سواء بسبب الاوضاع السياسيه او
تراجع الكميه المستخرجه اصلا وهي من حدار
منذ سنه
وايضا هناك حاله
من القلق وحاله من من التوقف سببت او
الازمه السياسيه الموجوده سببت حاله شلل
للاقتصاد الوطني الان هناك
معطيات او مؤشرات الحقيقه
مخيفه في تعامل البنوك العالميه مع البنوك
اليمنيه هناك صعوبات كثيره توضع الان ايضا
هناك توقف لحاله
الاستثمار ما بعد بعد هذه الاحداث
السياسيه التي شهدتها اليمن
وقد لا تستطيع الحكومه اذا ما استمرت
الظروف الراهنه دفع مرتبات ما بعد شهرين
او ثلاث اشهر ما لم يتم تدارك الامر
والوصول الى حاله من الاتفاق السياسي
والاستقرار الامني تقود الى او تعيد
الاوضاع على الاقل الى طبيعتها وبالتالي
عوده حاله من الاستقرار ولو النسبي الوضع
الاقتصادي وضع خطر للغ وهناك حاله من
الركود وتراجع في الموارد العامه للدوله
قد تصل الى 60% اليمن تعتمد بصوره اساسيه
على واردات النفط الذي تشكل اكثر من 50%
من الواردات للبلد وايضا حتى بالنسبه
للعائدات من الضرائب والجمارك ايضا بسبب
الركود الحاصل حاليا بسبب الاحداث
السياسيه قد يتراجع بصوره
كبيره انت ربطت ربطت بين العامل السياسي
وبين العامل الاقتصادي وان سؤالي موجه
لضيف الاستاذ جمال الحضرمي هل بامكان
انصار الله الحوثييين وهم يتصيدون او عفوا
يتصدرون الان المشهد السياسي والامني في
اليمن لوحدهم ان يقوموا بخطوات بامكانها
ان تنقذ هذا
الاقتصاد يا سيدي الاقتصاد اليمني لن
يتحسن الا عندما تكون السياسات الاقتصاديه
موجهه لتحقيق نمو اقتصادي حقيقي لحفاظ على
النفوذ السياسي لاي نظام كان ولاي
تكتل واي تي نظام سياسي قادم لابد ان يتخذ
حزمه من الاجراءات والاصلاحات التي ستزعج
النافذين داخل هذه الانظمه السياسيه التي
لا لا تعمل حسابها الحقيقي للاقتصاد
اليمني مما تعكس هذا الكلام يعكس على
القرار الاقتصادي فيتراجع نحن اخذنا اشوف
التجربه خلال الفتره الماضيه ال الاخوه
انصار الله استخدموا ان هناك الحزمه
السياسيه وان الجراه هي سبب المشكله
وتوالت الاحداث هذه هي نفس الاجراءات التي
تتخذ في المستقبل لاي حكومه قادمه سواء
كان لانصار الله او لحكومه ائتلاف وطني او
اي حكومه قادمه وستبدا المسيره من جديد
اذا لم توجد قناعات سياسيه حقيقيه لمعالجه
الوضع الاقتصادي اليمني وبقرارات حاسمه
وبقرارات تؤمن بانه البديل ليس هو فقط
انحن نكافح الفساد ولكن ايضا نتخذ اجراءات
حقيقيه لتحقيق نمو اقتصادي ومواجهه هذا
هذه الاقتصاد الريعي المعتمد على النفط
فقط هذا اللي اريد ان اقوله طيب بعد فاصل
قصير سنخوض في مساله قدره الحوثيين على
مواجهه ثوره جياع محتمله في اليمن تفضلوا
بالبقاء
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذا هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش مستقبل الدوله في اليمن مع
انتهاء المهله التي حددها الحوثيون لسد
الفراغ السياسي فيه واجدد تحيه لضيوفي من
صنعاء وكذلك من صعده وابقى في صعده مع
ضيفي الاستاذ محمد البخيتي البعض يقول بان
ما استعمله الحوثيون كحجه في مقارعه
الحكومه السابقه وتحديدا فيما يتعلق
بمساله الجرعه الان يلوح به في وجه انصار
الله على اساس انكم لن تقدروا على ان وفر
اليمنيين ما كنتم تطالبون به وتدون به ما
ردك اولا نتيجه الانخفاض اسعار النفط
فبالتالي لو استمر الفساد فان الحكومه
بحاجه الى اضافه المزيد على اسعار
المشتقات النفطيه من اجل مواجهه الازمه
يعني لو بقيت الحكومه السابقه الحكومه
الفاسده فان رفع الدعم عن المشتقات
النفطيه لا يكفي لدمع لدفع رواتب
المواطنين كما كانت هذا من ناحيه من
الناحيه ثانيه رفع اسعار المشتقات النصفيه
وخصوصا ماده الديزل لها اثار سلبيه على
الاقتصاد اليمني لانه لان الجميع يعرف ان
الاقتصاد اليمني يعتمد في 70% تقريبا على
الزراعه 50% من هذه الزراعه تعتمد تقريبا
على المياه الجوفيه وبالتالي عند رفع
اسعار الديزل فان الكثير من المزارعين
سيتوقفون على اج وهذا سيضاعف الازمه
الاقتصاديه هذا والحل والحل في هذه
الحاله نعم المشكله الاقتصاديه الان هي
موجوده هي ليست من صنيعه انصار الله ولكن
لو لو استمر الوضع على ما هو عليه استشراء
الفساد وايضا تحميل المواطن
كلفه العجز في الميزانيه عبر رفع رفع
المشتقات النفطيه باكثر مما كانت عليه في
عهد حكومه الوفاق فهذا سيؤدي الى تدمير
الاقتصاد اليمني ودخال ما الذي ما الذي
يختلف عندما اعتصمتم في العاصمه صنعاء
نتيجه قرارات الحكومه في ما يتعلق برفع او
رفع الدعم عن اسعار بعض المحروقات
واحتجزتهم فيما يعرف بقضيه الجرعه وما هو
الوضع عليه الان بغض النظر عن ارتفاع او
انخفاض سعر
البترول الان انصار الله استطاعوا ان
يوفروا المليارات لخزينه الدوله حذا
استطاعت اللجان الشعبيه حتى الان القضاء
على بعض منابع الفساد وهي مستمره في
القضاء على كل نابع الفساد وال الضغطه
الذي مارسنا اخيرا على السلطه هي كان من
اجل مكافحه الفساد ايضا نحن الزمنا الان
التجار على دفع الضرائب كان هناك متاخرات
كثيره من الضرائب تقدر بمليارات الريالات
مثلا شركه سبافون التي كان يديرها حميد
الاحمر عليها متاخرات باكثر من 3 مليار
ريال
ا
ايضا الان اصبحت ال
اصبحت بيئه الاستثمار في اليمن بيئه
صالحه لان لان في السابق كان التجار الذين
هم مرتبطين بالسلطه يستخدمون نودهم
لعرقله منافسيهم
من من المستثمرين سواء مستثمرين يمنيين في
الداخل او مستثمرين يريدون الاستثمار في
اليمن اذا هناك مليارات الريالات موجوده
في اليمن هنا اسال ضيفي ايضا الخبير
الاقتصادي الاستاذ مصطفى نصر هل نحن امام
كما يقول ضيفنا السييد البخيتي توفير
لمليارات الريالات موجوده الان في اليمن
ام نحن الان امام كلام الاستهلاك
الاعلامي
ا اعتقد اعتقد ان الفساد انا اتفق مع الاخ
البخيتي بان الفساد يشكل واحده من
التحديات التي اعاقه التنميه في البلد وهو
ومكافحه الفساد بصوره رسميه وشعبيه ايضا
اي امر مهم للغايه لكن اود ان اوضح التالي
ان الوضع الاقتصادي في البلد اليوم بحاجه
الى ان يكون هناك استقرار سياسي وامني ما
لم يكن هناك استقرار سياسي وامني لن يتحقق
شيء في الجانب التنموي لان الان هناك
عقبات كبيره فيما يتعلق بتوقف شركات انتاج
النفط بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه وايضا هناك
حاله من الضغط من البنوك الدوليه للتعامل
مع الوضع الخطر في اليمن وهذا يعيق كثيرا
اي ايضا تراجع الاحتياطي النقدي من
العملات الصعبه بسبب تراجع اسعار النفط
وتراجع كميه النفط المنتجه اضف الى ذلك
العديد من التحديات التي تواجه البيئه
الاستثماريه اليوم المؤشرات الاقتصاديه
فيما يتعلق بالاستثمار خلال الربع الاخير
تراجعت بصوره كبيره وفقا لاخر الاحصائيات
لان هناك حاله من القلق لا يعرف
المستثمرون ما هو المستقبل غدا وما هي
الصوره وما هي السيناريوهات
السياسيه لليمن خلال عام 2015 و206 وهذه
تلقي بضلالها على الوضع الاقتصادي بصوره
كبيره اليمن بحاجه الى اتفاق سياسي وايضا
استقرار امني يق وايضا حكومه كفاءات وليست
حكومه تتبع اي طرف من الاطراف
لكي تحدث نوع من التنميه بناء على سياسات
اقتصاديه تقوم على انقاذ البلد من هذه
اللحظه الحريه للاسف الشديد ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالمشتقات النفطيه طيب سؤالي موج
سيد جمال الحضرمي من عفوا سيد مصطفى من
يحذر الان بان اليمن مقبل على لا قدر الله
ثوره جياع هل هو تحليل له ما يبرره ام
هناك مبالغه في توصيف الوضع في اليمن في
ظل ما ذكره قبل قليل ضيفنا الاستاذ محمد
البخي عندما قال بان هناك اجراءات هناك
خطوات يتم اتخاذها من اجل تشفيه منابع
الفساد
وكذلك دفع التجار لدفع
الضرائب
الحقيقه هذه عوامل مبشره ان ان يكون هناك
قدره حقيقيه من قبل نظام سياسي معين على
اداره الاقتصاد بحزم ومكافحه الفساد بفكر
وثقافه ورؤيه وليس فقط بحديث نحن امامنا
اول شيء اول شيء ان كثير من القوى النفوذ
التي كانت مواليه لانظمه سابقه هي انتقلت
الى نظام سياسي جديد هذا يجب ان نفهمه
وبالتالي سيكون قدرتها على الضغط لهذا
النظام السياسي مما يعكس صعوبه في اتخاذ
القرارات
الاقتصاديه لذلك اقول انه اول خطوه يجب ان
تخرج اليمن من مازق هذا المازق الخطير
اللي تعيشه الان وهو مازق التهديدات
والصراعات بين القوى السياسيه والانتقال
مباشره الى اتخاذ قرار اقتصادي حازم عبر
حكومه كفاءات تؤمن بان النمو الاقتص
الاقتصادي هو طريقها وتعرف بان لا يمكن
تحقيق هذا النمو الاقتصادي الا بحزمه من
الاصلاحات يتفق عليها وتقر من كافه
الاطراف السياسيه وانا تعبث بمقدرات البلد
من خلال مهاترات سياسيه تؤدي الى تخريب
وتؤدي الى انهاك الاقتصاد اليمني الاقتصاد
اليمني هو اقتصاد ريعي بسيط سهل لا يعتمد
على القطاع الزراعي والقطاع النفطي وعلى
الثروه السمكيه وصادراتها اذا لم توجد
قدره على تشغيل هذه القطاعات وقطاع
الصناعه وقطاع الاستخراج اذا لم يكون هناك
قدره على تشغيل هذه القطاعات بعيدا عن
المهاترات السياسيه والنفوذ واصحاب النفوذ
والتدخلات من اي مكان ستكون الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه بالتاكيد افضل وانا ارى انه
ولو قطت حديثي ان فقط ان استهلاك الاسره
اليمنيه 4% من انفاقها يتجه نحو المواد
الغذائيه فاذا لم نوفر لهذه الاسره
استقرار غذائي وامن حقيقي في الغذاء لا
ادى الى الى ال الى انهيارات نحن نعيش في
ادنى مستوى للفقر نحن نعيش في 4 مليون
نسمه من السكان يعيشون تحت مستوى الفقر و1
مليون من السكان يعيشون في في ظروف صعبه
طيب استاذ محمد البخيتي يجمع ضيفي على
الموازنه بين اي حل اقتصادي لا يمكن ان
يتم الا في ظل وضع سياسي مختلف مبن على
التوافق اليوم تنتهي المهله التي حددتم من
اجل توافق سياسي من اجل مجلس رئاسي ماذا
في حال عدم التوفيق في هذه المساله هل
مستعدون لتحمل المسؤوليه
لوحدكم طبعا اولا هناك تقدم كبير تقدم
ايجابي في المفاوضات بين القوى السياسيه
واتوقع ان يخرجوا اليوم باتفاق او يوم غد
وبالتالي نحن متفائلين الان بان القوى
السياسيه قد اتجهت نحو حل الحله الوضع
السياسي في اليمن وانا اتفق ايضا مع
الاخوان في قضيه
الاستقرار الاقتصاد يحتاج الى الاستقرار
وخصوصا جذب الاستثمارات الخارجيه وكما
تلاح وكما يلاحظ كل اليمنيين ان المناطق
الان التي يتواجد فيها انصار الله قد
اصبحت امنه واصبح الاستثمار فيها
امن وان التهديد على اقتصاد ياتي من
الاطراف الاخرى وكما يسمع الجميع ان هناك
تهديدات من قبل بعض المحسوبين على السياسي
والاحزاب يتكلم عن نتكلم عن عن دوله من
الحدود الى الحدود وليس على مناطق تقع تحت
سيطره الانصار الله وبالتالي يمكن القياس
عليه وهنا سؤالي موجه لضيف استاذ مصطفى
نصر كيف ترى مستقبل الوضع في الايام
القليله
القادمه في حال استمرت المعطيات الره نا
في حال استمرت المعطيات الراهنه انا اقول
ان البلد يتجه نحو انهيار وشيك والحكومه
غير قادره خلال ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر اذا
ما استمرت المعطيات عن دفع مرتبات و
وستواجه الحكومه صعوبات في قضيه تامين
استيراد المواد الاساسيه هذا في السيناريو
الاسوا لكن في حال فعلا وصلت القوى
السياسيه الى حاله من الاتفاق وتم الاتفاق
على ان يكون هناك حكومه كفاءات تدير الشان
الاقتصادي بعيدا عن السيطره السياسيه انا
اعتقد انه يمكن ان ان تعود الامور على
الاقل الى الى نصابها
مع مع مواجهه الصعوبات الراهنه الان بكل
تاكيد البلد يواجه صعوبات كبيره اقتصاديه
جراء كما قلت تراجع اسعار النفط والمشتقات
النفطيه ايضا واضافه الى انه حاله الركود
الاقتصاديه التي وصلت الى 70 الى 70 الى
60% هذه اثرت على النشاط الاقتصادي بصوره
عامه وبالتالي خلال المرحله الراهنه بحاجه
الى استقرار بحيث تعود الامور على الاقل
الى المستوى الطبيعي مصطفى نصر رئيس مركز
الاعلام الاقتصادي كنت معنا من صنعاء شكرا
جزيلا لك وكذلك اشكر ضيفي من صنعاء جمال
الحضرمي مستشار رئيس الوزراء المستقيل
لشؤون الاقتصاد كما اشكر ضيفي من صعده
محمد البخيتي عضو المجلس السياسي لجماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين بذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء